I think belief is universal we all  believe in something  [Music]  what I believe that can't be proven baby  see how I wanna see existence did you  I play for God the Father God son died  later so Debra reserves area that is  very strong that could mean the  collective consciousness in the Psalter  dobra Carmen papa you did you record I  believe in love but you can't prove love  you can I see love in late night oh what  a musical public opinion across pourquoi  tenure track line team the argument of  America we are on the toaster  so now something else why y'all noise I  believe the spirit hey guy did he some  way out from JV soccer I'm a very  scientific person engineering background  so definitely know the adilyn business  Logan was about to officially signing  for the bottle master a product of our  popular on I believe in nothing yo get  rid of to what I'm just looking  [Music]